stars on three I like playing for seven
stars because it makes me feel strong
I'm proud to play for the salon stars
because I get to represent other Muslim
girls around the world this lamb stars
are bigger than basketball because we're
breaking all stereotypes of the world
for chase about us I want people to know
that we're just a group of teenage girls
are coming to play basketball and work
as hard as we can and win that's our
goal
[Music]
my name is Genevieve and I'm a senior
captain on the slams co-stars Salaam
schools with all private Muslim school
and Salaam stars is a girls varsity
basketball team with all female Muslim
athletes who go out there and represent
a religion while playing basketball last
year we won a lot of games we're a great
team and the way we got to being great
team is our hard work our chemistry
especially the way we play who kind of
like a family it's important to have
that kind of bond because people look
down on us because of what we wear then
think that we don't know how to play but
when we go out there and show them how
we do play it feels great because we've
showed them who we really are as a team
[Music]
I've been playing basketball since I was
13
I watched my brothers play and it was
just around me all the time I like
basketball cuz it's intense and you're
moving around and I like the physicality
having supportive family actually helped
me a lot because it makes me feel
confident playing basketball especially
because we do we present our religion
through it going on a road game is like
kind of leaving all the support you have
behind you're going into a school where
people really don't know what your
religion is like sometimes we see them
laughing feeling like whispering to each
other it's frustrating because you're
trying to win the game and then you're
having like negative comments in your
ear but at the same time we have to push
through the hate we get I told my
teammates just ignore it and if they
can't ignore it just show them by
playing basketball no just push hard
push through what they say
coach cast knows what we go through on
and off the court and as the years gone
she's learned a lot from us when I first
got here I didn't know anything about
Islam and I relied on the older senior
leadership on the team and even to this
day I rely on the senior captains to
tell me like if it's time for prayer and
they'll come up to me like coach can we
pray I'm like absolutely
it's not just about basketball here
we're trying to build confident young
women but I'm just in awe at how the
girls carry themselves so well I'm very
proud of being their coach
it's not just about the sport it's how
you work together the commitment you
give to the team and the way you play
together on the court no matter what
goes on you play your hardest I want
people to know that Muslim female
athletes are nothing different we're
girls who just want to play basketball
we're nothing different than any other
girls team we are proud we wear the
scarf we are proud that we present a
religion playing basketball and nothing
will stop us
[Music]